Attention deficit hyperactivity disorder is one of the most common childhood
disorders in the United States. And it can continue into adolescence and
adulthood. According to the National Institute of Mental Health, symptoms
include difficulty staying focused and paying attention, difficulty in
controlling behavior and hyperactivity. Let's look at three types of symptoms.
First we have inattention. Someone who has symptoms of inattention can be
easily distracted. They may miss details or forget things and they frequently
switch from one behavior activity to another. They can become bored with a task
after only a few minutes, unless they are doing something that they really
enjoy. This means they can have trouble completing or turning in homework
assignments. They often lose things needed to complete a task, and they seem to
not listen when spoken to. Furthermore, they may daydream, become easily
confused, and even struggle to follow directions or instructions. A child who
has symptoms of hyperactivity may squirm or fidget in their seat. Someone with
symptoms of hyperactivity may talk nonstop. They may run around touching and
playing with everything in sight. They have trouble sitting still at dinner, at
school. And thus they may get in trouble from teachers as well as parents for
their hyperactivity. Now let's look at impulsivity. Symptoms of impulsivity
means a person may be very impatient. They may blurt out inappropriate comments
or show their emotions without restraint. And they may often act out without
regard for consequences. They may have difficulty waiting for things that they
want, and they may interrupt people's conversations or activities. Now as you
can imagine, children experiencing a combination of these symptoms, can
experience great difficulty in managing their day to day behaviors that are
necessary, and needed for doing well in school, or interacting with others, and
completing a daily routine. And not all attention deficit disorders will be
exactly the same. You'll see some who are more inattentive rather than
hyperactive, and some who are more impulsive rather than inattentive. In order
to be diagnosed with ADHD, one must meet a set of diagnostic criteria. That is
comprised of a number of symptoms of this disorder. And now the causes of ADHD,
or Attention Deficit Hyper-activity Disorder, include a combination of genes,
and environmental factors. Now for a long time, people suspected that the
consumption of sugar caused ADHD. However, there's no research that's provided
support for that idea.